it's hard to explain the engineering
Marvel that is the SR71 Blackbird
entirely unique engines were needed to
function from zero all the way up to
mock 3.2 how on Earth did it manage that
in order to achieve those kinds of
speeds a Ramjet is typically needed a
Ramjet as you can probably guess from
the name relies on RAM pressure to
operate Ram pressure is simply the
pressure that occurs as a plane Rams
itself through through the air so as the
engine moves through the sky it funnels
this high-press air inside before
entering the combustion chamber the
supersonic airf flow must be first
slowed down this basically acts like the
compressor stage of a normal jet engine
elevating the air pressure before it
enters the combustion chamber once the
air enters the combustion chamber it is
mixted fuel and ignite it it expands and
accelerates once again out of the exit
nozzle